[Music]
tonight speaker has not spoken here at
the interval in fact the proto version
of the interval too long now Museum and
store was not even a glimmer in this
organization's eye when he did speak for
long now in 2004 about 13 and a half
years ago exactly from tonight he spoke
in the room that is at the end of this
large building this old Fort Mason
building and that talk was about the
singularity your future is a black hole
so the uplifting topics are really
Bruce's niche and and we're thrilled to
have that but Bruce it was invoked in
this space in 2015 when when Neil
Stevenson was speaking about seven eaves
I don't know if he knows this but as
Neil said my friend and colleague Bruce
Sterling defines a thriller as any novel
that features the President of the
United States as a character so I guess
this is one of those so and I I think
that you know this is the kind of zone
we're moving into the kind of mode we're
about to be in the Bruce Sterling mode
there there are profound things and very
self-evident truths that that mix
between the the mundane and and the
stellar and he is he is going to no
doubt leave us enthralled and bewildered
and you'll all get a chance to ask him
questions as soon as this is done when
he finished up his talk which you can
you can hear it's part of our long now
podcast series the way he ended it in
2004 was the future is not a noun it's a
verb
and we're never going to stop futuring
and with that let's get some future and
going on big round of applause for Britt
Farrah and Bruce are our apologies for
for for auto auto it has obviously
gotten tongue-tied that's okay we're not
the first piece of technology art I've
seen shattered so yeah it's um it's
pleasant to be here in your legendary
long now bar which I've never visited
before nice intimate colorful venue got
here
makes you want to drink single malt
whiskey and tell fantastic bar stories
you know like maybe a time travel story
would be appropriate so like there's
this futurist and he's in this bar and
he's like telling the crowd about how to
be futuristic and he's getting really
warmed up you know about like doing
quadrant scenarios and dentil fight
Paul's and the whole nine yards but then
some little guy in the back raises his
hand and the crowd and he's like wait a
minute
I'm a time traveler and I actually live
in the future and I'd like to study the
futurism of the past so I came back here
to tell you guys how to really do it and
then there's like some satire and the
story and and then there's like this
cool twist ending and then the story's
just over I mean like bang no it's just
stories gone so that's a major problem
in how to be futuristic though writing
about it because narratives have
beginnings and middles and ends and you
know a climax and adenomas and quite
often there's a moral to the story at
the end but time I mean the process of
time passing has none of those things
they're all impositions from sort of the
way people think and so that the stories
we tell one another and the way prose is
constructed so the future is not a story
and the future really is a process it's
not a destination and when you get to
next week you're not in the future
you're always in the present
okay so as a futurist when you hear a
good story like a good bar story that's
got like a really nice firm conclusion
and it kind of like makes its point
you're like wow what a great story you
should always ask what happens next
I've been just plunking Lee asked it
just like getting the mental habit of
understanding that even though words
always have to stop time does not stop
even huge events don't stop it I mean
things are like we have ceremonies for
it like he's dead and we buried him or I
loved her and I married her but you know
that doesn't mean it that leaves I mean
the leaves continue to fall off the
calendar I mean the mere fact that he's
dead and he's buried it means something
to us but it doesn't actually stop
anything
I mean after his death things just roll
right along and and people who never
heard of his death are not affected by
it in any way and but any more than
somebody who hasn't heard my bar story
is affected by my bars story so you know
the word time is not the same as the
objective phenomenon of time because
nobody knows what time is I mean we can
measure it with like increasing
precision but we don't and we can talk
about it and we can feel it but we can't
define it I mean you can't go out and
buy a quart of it
we can't mine it we can't store it you
know we can't we can't really do
anything about it except advance into
the future at the rate of one second per
second right so there is a school of
thought that says that the future
doesn't exist like there is no future
because time itself does not exist
there's no really no such thing as time
what really exists metaphysically
according to this idea is matter in
motion in a series of material events in
space and stuff moves around and bangs
into each other and we call that time
because we need a convenient word for
what's happening but the word is just an
abstraction I mean there there is no
time there's just matter banging into
space so there's no such thing as next
week
right and there's no last week either
last week was real because it left
traces in the now but there's not a last
week that you can reach from here not
like the world of last week the world of
the past is not a world it's just a
figure of speech and reality is just
this propagating wave front of the
moving matter the only thing that is
real is the moment of the now and since
we're at the long now bar its interest
me to speculate like how long is that
now I mean the now that is real that is
not the past nor the future I mean how
long does it last right I mean how thick
is it is it like ten thousand years
thick because you know Brian Eno would
think that was a cool idea or you know
or maybe maybe this present moment you
know reality the thing that is not the
past not the future but just actually
the moment maybe it's amazingly thin it
was like the thinnest possible quantum
blip of real time like the time that a
light wave takes to cross the diameter
of an electron like that the absolute
thinnest kind of time you could possibly
measure you know and that's like reality
the actual existent world that is not
the lost past or the imaginary future
maybe it's a billion times thinner than
a heartbeat
it's the ultra short now it's the Planck
second it's the smallest theoretical
measurable unit of nowness is all that
is real now I'm allowed to talk that way
in bars
because I'm a science fiction writer and
I can offer the opposite scenario to you
know and not contradict myself and and
the opposite is almost his way out and
marvelous okay now dig this
another school of thought that thinks
that time doesn't exist because the past
and the future are real and the now is
not real I mean only the past and the
future are real and it's the now that's
the illusion right the present is unreal
there is no real present the now is an
illusion and reality is actually one
vast solid four dimensional time-space
block that starts with the beginning of
the universe the Big Bang 13.8 billion
years ago and it stretches toward its
end near the heat death of the universe
whatever comes beyond it now there's an
entity that exists outside of space-time
and can observe all of this block at
once and that's probably God I mean he's
is the unmoved mover he's the primal
cause time cannot affect him he's
omnipotent he's omniscient of course
he's omniscient cuz he can see the past
and future because to him is just like a
black monolith it just kind of like
gazes down here gazes up there
everything's fine reality is a
deterministic fate bound universe
because there is no authentic difference
between the future in the past according
to the Creator they're really the same
entity and you can go up the block or
you can go down the block and the
physics will work out fine either way if
you just run everything in Reverse run
the tape backwards it's groovy right so
there's no problem so the long now is
actually all the time that there could
ever be right it's the longest possible
now it's contained in one cosmic black
monolith like a single jewel like monad
that would make the Philosopher's
Leibnitz like really overjoyed now you
know I'm a guy who by his temperament is
a thrilled with Fantasia
metaphysical musings but you know is
that actually how to be futuristic me
what I just did there like the
speculating about time and sort of like
what is the future okay suppose suppose
I'm on an island like Robinson Crusoe
and the novel by Daniel Defoe fictional
island but I'm also a meta physician and
I'm a mathematician and I specialize in
relativistic space-time theories so I'm
like a super futuristic guy and I'm like
drawing diagrams in the sand all by
myself naked we're in like a goatskin
hat and they're probably Feynman
diagrams cuz I've been really up to
speed I mean I'm genuine intellectual
here and I'm seriously pondering the
future I mean just all by myself though
am i a futurist can I be a futurist
under those conditions I'm pretty sure
that I'm not I'm not a futurist and the
reason is I don't have anybody to tell
about it
no really it's a social construction I'm
not even a scientist because I can't
publish and test my findings which is
required by the scientific method now
I'm basically a diarist
and probably going slowly crazy right so
you know being aware of the future and
even personally behaving in a farsighted
way that is not how to be futuristic
I mean how to be futuristic as a
performance to be a futurist you have to
declare yourself to be a futurist within
some community of futuristic practice
right it's not a thing you can do all by
yourself so for instance to be a science
fiction brand a futurist I have to
publish some science fiction if I just
write my weird musings about the future
in my private diary nobody's ever gonna
know this is gonna make zero difference
I have to participate in some kind of
publishing system I have to be involved
in the literary world in some way and I
have to communicate otherwise I'm the
Crusoe guy
telling himself bar stories alone so for
me to write a novel about the future
though somebody has to invent the
literary concept of writing a novel with
a setting which is in the future and
that did not happen until the 1600s
I mean people were writing stories for
millennia before anybody thought why
don't I just set it in the time to come
somebody had to and you know undertake
this literary invention it had never
occurred to anybody it was a kind of
Kopernik and breakthrough it was like
wait I could set it in the past or I
could set it at the day I rank it like
said it in the future and like this
happened like 10 or 12 times by
different authors before anybody really
caught on and thought you know this
could work it was like independently
invented by a large variety of kind of
Robinson Crusoe style or science fiction
writers who just did broke these
eccentric things and nobody picked it up
nobody went anywhere with it there was
no futuristic community of practice they
would just write it and have it go on so
it was impossible at that time to be
futuristic in the science fictional way
you just couldn't do it until people had
a discourse of scientific romance right
a way to talk about it and they had a
publishing structure and a distribution
structure and an audience and some
literary cliques and also some critical
responses and before those things were
invented you just couldn't do it it was
just it was beyond the capacity but
after they were invented then you could
be a science fictional futurist mostly
through declaring to other people that
you were one and you and they had to
hear you and they had to agree they had
to validate your declaration it's like
yeah you're one of us here's your Hugo
Award you know whatever I am you could
join the science fiction writers of
America but without them you're just
you're the Robinson Crusoe guy you know
drawing weird diagrams now that seems
fine I better have some water here
really getting into it but but you know
see there's there's a discrepancy
between these literary modes of
expression and the nature of the actual
passage of time like I'm not really
writing about what time does when I'm
being a science fictional futurist and
for instance old-fashioned science
fiction is futuristic and tone but it is
not contemporary it's an outdated and
archaic form of expression and this
creates a kind of slippage which I like
to call a temper ality and no a
temporality is basically a metaphysical
problem in the way that words are nailed
on to reality like you know you could
talk about the past and you can talk
about the future but then the time also
affects the words and the words are
affected by time you know sentences
change their meaning new forms of jargon
appear ideas become old-fashioned and
eventually the text becomes cluttered
with so many RK isms that you can no
longer regard it as futuristic right you
just recognize that it's that it's a
period artifact so you can't you can't
divorce the words from the passage of
time you know the words are socially
generated in society changes right now
if you're aware of these changes you can
play certain tricks but mostly verbal
tricks but you know that's not even
being futuristic to be futuristic is to
perform the futuristic for somebody it's
an act of communication from a futurist
to an audience and if you want to make a
success of that endeavor you have to
cultivate the audience I mean you must
specialize so you may well have heard of
the stewards specially if you're Stuart
brand so
in this in this very interesting pace
layer idea notion we all share the same
calendar I mean you know the Sun rises
seconds go by you know what we can have
a relativistic timeframe a little bit
but we're all sharing the same time but
human events do not proceed with the
same rate of change they don't change at
the same rate they're all in the same
calendar but some move slowly and some
move move quickly so there are some
areas of human activities where things
tend to be quite frenetic kind of antic
and then there are others that are
rather solemn and then there's some that
are even pre human like slow geologic
deep time cosmic time spans and these
pace layers would be called fashion
commerce governance infrastructure
culture and nature and in the rate of
their speed so fashion changes the
fastest and nature changes quite slowly
so I'm actually a sceptic about pace
layers even though I write about them
all the time I'm not sure that they
objectively exist but I have noticed
that practicing futurists who are
successful tend to specialize in one
layer so for instance hip trendy trends
fighting people they like fashion
they're just comfortable they're there
at their ease in fashion this year's
color the statement fabrics with the
decor and the five star bar looks like
in other words a guy like Karl Lagerfeld
this guy Karl Lagerfeld is always
dependably ahead of the fashion curve
even though he's ancient
he's a white-haired guy it looks a
hundred years old now Karl is a genuine
futurist guru because he publishes books
of wise timeless ever is ameed
Karl Karl is basically the world's
deepest superficial guy I can promise
you that the presidents of France are
personally afraid of Karl Karl is a
creative but mostly Karl is a
trend-spotting entrepreneurial lifestyle
packager that's what he does maybe is a
guru but he's also a businessman so if
you want to be futuristic in the
fast-moving fashion world even over a
long period because he's had quite an
extensive career you would need to have
a pretty good look at Karl Lagerfeld I I
would consider him the Bo ideal of a guy
who's being futuristic in the fashion
layer then there's the next layer down
which would be the commerce pace layer
and we're in an extremely market centric
society at this point in history
trending toward feudal oligarchy
actually but still very commercial and
temperament that's what people sort of
expect and this is the operative realm
of futurists who prefer to be called
strategic forecasters so guys like
Forrester Gartner lots of you know
commercial forecasting operations
plenty of elbow room for them because
there's a lot of profitable business
going on and a lot of guys who want
their advice so I hang out with
strategic forecasters and sometimes I
could solve for businesses myself I
don't mind them I do find that these
strategic forecasters always frame stuff
in terms of Commerce though they very
rarely move from the face layer to talk
about fashion or to talk about
government it's always business I mean
they're stucked in the layer with the
business in it I mean that they want to
be within the money the money paradigm
and the most successful ones tend to be
motivational speakers for the investment
class they're not actually interested in
the future or the past they're just
trying to convince people to try to make
more money and you know and to like
legitimate their activities within the
world of Commerce and you know people
who are in business imagine that they
are hard-headed realistic people who
really have a lot of of a tough-as-nails
inside
to what's really going on but they're
quite fantastic actually and panicky
kind of people for instance they're
stuck in a situation today where eighty
or so super-rich moguls oligarchs
basically control all their marbles
they're not really in a market business
at all but they don't recognize it and
it's not very innovative or
entrepreneurial and business at this
moment they say that it is but actually
it in a condition of industry
consolidation and high technology
Moore's law has died in fact it was
killed for commercial reasons the middle
class is an extensive misery all around
the world and the real estate business
which is supposedly the most solid blue
chip investment it's just catching fire
blowing over and drowning it's quite a
gloomy area that's the particular
business pace layer
you know people that business are in a
filter bubble they're really not well
served by their advisers and then
there's the next layer down which is the
governance layer now you used to see a
lot of scientific council within
government there's a common thing during
most of my life span Offices of
Technology Assessment and so forth a lot
of these guys cluttering up the scene in
government they are a dying breed
because fundamentalist and oligarchs
both despise science they don't want to
have anything to have they won't have
anything to do with them now in this
ancient standard of futurism the gold
standard is veneer blush from the 1940s
who was one of the inventors of the
atomic bomb a master engineer of the
Manhattan Project he was also the father
of the American National Science
Foundation because he wrote the
extremely important futurist text
science the endless frontier that screed
is probably the greatest work of
futurism ever put onto paper with a
typewriter it's really an impressive
governmental document and you know and
aimed at the head of state so there's
still a problem with this it's like why
isn't science as respected as it was and
I think the problem there is cultural
and because Americans and especially
Californians have a severe moral problem
with the idea that frontiers and
that they're not endless in fact that
gold rush is just get old and die ugly
they're not always young and pretty and
beautiful and glamorous and
forward-looking they get old and cranky
and weird you know and I like obsessed
with themselves and it kind of like
moved from you know who it was right
from savagery to barbarism without
civilization ever occurring savagery
barbarism to decadence without without a
civilization is a typical frontier
development so you know to think that
the science is an endless frontier is
actually a bad paradigm especially for a
futurist or a scientist
for instance paleontology is an
important science which is about things
that ended a long time ago and they just
ended they're not gone they're not gonna
revive you're not gonna improve the
trilobite s-- right just but it's
important to understand what's going on
in geologic time whether there's
anything to do with it or not and there
are also many areas of scientific
investigation that are not endless
frontiers are dead ends I mean they're
called to sacks they have to be
abandoned such as phlogiston you know or
the luminiferous ether
or spontaneous generation or even some
aspects of Newtonian physics I mean they
just they're not up to speed and you
know you have to let those go scientific
truth is provisional it's not permanent
and eternal and science as a human
Enterprise I mean the actual business of
science and I how scientists are
recruited promoted how they quote one
another that's a very time bound very
social kind of situation the change is
quite a lot as time as time goes on so
if you think that atomic physics or
maybe the truth of atomic physics the
scientific truth of atomic physics is
somehow an eternal thing then you have
to go all-out for nuclear power or giant
gadgets like these superconducting
supercollider which is unwise I mean
that ambition is going to end in tears
if you ask the government for 11 billion
dollars for a superb scientific
instrument that is not going to work
it's just you can't it can't be built
that is bad politics it's poor
statesmanship you're a scientific
futurist but you gave bad advice so if
you're a scientific futurist and you're
in the government pace layer you can't
simply say to them I have some
Inconvenient Truth here look at this
math it won't work you have to say I
have some Inconvenient Truth here and I
can use it to win world war two with a
secret super weapon that was the van Eva
Bush method and that's that's what life
is like and the government pay slayer
when things are really cracking right
along now below the government pays
layer is the infrastructure layer and I
know some people claim that government
is slower than infrastructure like
infrastructure should be up here and
like government should be down there but
I don't believe that I don't believe it
because I hang out in Italy where you
can have 10 governments in 10 years and
the infrastructure is 2,000 years old
so futurist guys who are trying to rid
our world of the curse of fossil fuels
these are the guys working in this layer
very resistant guys in the Emirates who
build super skyscrapers or in the
infrastructure layer military futurists
busily terraforming the South China Sea
with unsinkable Chinese aircraft
carriers that's an infrastructure thing
engineers are there Architects are there
smart city planners urban development
guys a lot of infrastructure innovation
going on but it tends to take at least
10 years to see the first results of
basically anything just it just takes a
long time it certainly does pile up in
the long run however and good old Italy
you can see literal centuries of
infrastructure development just laid out
on the landscape like a layer cake
then there's the culture layer which is
the realm of poets and prophets and
visionaries and saints and historical
novelists and science fiction writers
now I've spent a lot of my creative
career trying to figure out if
historical novels and futuristic novels
are actually the same cultural activity
are they really the same thing just like
with a pole reversal going on I think
that prediction and retro diction do
have areas of Concilium just like trying
to interpret the nature of time is like
something that's what's going on there
and I even noticed that a store achill
novel from the 1890s and a futuristic
scientific romance of the 1890s they
have the 1890s in common and and as time
passes they they become closer as like
literary artifacts they're like fossils
matched together under the the same
historic later right but culture is not
made of futurism culture is made from
classics it's made from the classics
people in the future
do not read future works of futurism
which are written about their own time
they're not interested in what futurists
think about them here in the 21st
century we rarely seek out and read old
sci-fi books that were written in the
1900s about the 21st century they don't
interest us you know except as curious
artifacts instead people in the future
read what people have been reading for
centuries they read the famous classics
right even ancient Greeks ancient Romans
ancient Chinese they have an audio it's
like a contemporary literary audience
and these are works that the future will
know very well they may know some of
them better than we do just because they
pay more attention to them right and
they're kind of willing to go in and
research certain areas of of literary
stuff that we overlook I mean they can
be closer to the past than we are and
that's very typical of activity in the
culture layer now people in 200 years
will probably not know any of our
contemporary movie stars like the ones
that we pay a lot of money for and like
but they will know who Charlie Chaplin
is even though Charlie Chaplin is you
know the exemplar of a dead medium
silent film which is no longer practiced
at all Chaplin will be around they will
understand his meaning they're not gonna
know the people who we think are like a
big deal at our particular time so if
you want to be a futurist who's working
on this cultural level you'd need some
knowledge of the humanities I mean you
really need to kind of be at ease in
this in this particular milieu and
you'll want to read people like Fernand
broad L and the long DeRay where he
argues that nothing much really
important happens in culture unless 300
years have passed and 300 years like the
right way to think things through
so novels can capture cultural
sensibility and preserve it for
centuries what works about futurism
mostly just don't I mean they just can't
they're too technical they're too
analytic they're not a bottle of culture
like a novel is that's why certain
contemporary things and situations can
be seen or described as Orwellian
Orwell's Ian or Abelard Ian or even
Clark Ian but you would rarely see them
described as Toffler Ian or Drucker Ian
or Peter Schwartz Ian you know even
though these writers are really pretty
good futurist writers with a lot to say
and I've read their work with a lot of
benefit I'm just not operating in the
cultural layer and then there's the
primeval and pre-human natural pace
layer which is supposed to be the realm
of paleontologists and geologists and
biologists and evolutionary theorists
and astronomers and astrophysicists now
here's the part where I get problematic
with the entire pace layer scheme I'm
afraid is getting top-heavy backward
they're not supposed to be rapid sharp
continuing catastrophes way down in the
nature layer that's not supposed to
happen according to the pace layer
scheme the nature layer is supposed to
be very laid-back very John Muir like
it's Thoreau vien Emersonian timeless
unchangeable it's not supposed to be an
anthropologist is invasive species huge
storms that can change shorelines faster
than fashionable hem
lines can change however that's
definitely what we're in for
now and in the future near future at
least and the notion that you might get
to pick and choose between the stately
layers it like you can go down to the
part that's like not disrupted is likely
to get thrown out on its ear base layers
may become an old-fashioned futuristic
idea just an archaic period notion from
a lost era of futurism so well how to be
futuristic in this particular era and
the coming years well there has never
been a time ever when popular culture
was so keen on dystopias we are really
really happy about these ideas the mass
consensus is one of dread that is the
mass consensus that's a central idea and
it's difficult to talk to people about
their future to perform futurism and
also tell them that they cannot plan
ahead rationally that there is no truly
secure way of life available anywhere
for anyone and then if they're going to
get repeatedly walloped by vast
unnatural catastrophes it's a very
difficult thing to kind of sell it's
it's it's not a beat but the near future
the mid 21st century is driven like most
centuries by demographics and
infrastructure but also climate change
it's its Emelia really of old people in
big cities afraid of the sky that's what
the middle of the 21st century looks
like lots of old people and really big
metropolis is terrified of climate
change and you know the future is a kind
of history that hasn't happened yet and
that just happens to be our part of the
coming role and you know people often
assure me that futurists can't predict
the future I could predict you with
great confidence that the world
population is in fact aging I'm not
going to start aging in Reverse you know
the calendars not gonna reverse I've
every 19-year old who's gonna be 19 is
19 now and 10 years from now he's gonna
be 29 and yeah I'm I'm pretty confident
about that cities are expanding and
densifying they've been doing this for
you know 50 60 years that
the trends are not exactly set in stone
it could be hit by meteors or something
but it's a very dependable trendline and
the climate is just unhinged like really
going nuts
so time will bear me out on this
prediction old people in big cities
afraid of the sky it's gonna bear me out
because it's happened already
I'm telling you about the present day
which is simply intensified I'm not like
making up something from from Oz the
truth is obvious anybody who wants to
pay attention anybody walking around in
the streets of California and see all of
these processes happening to us right
now just as they were happening here ten
years 20 years 30 years ago right so
it's not that you can't predict the
future it's more that and the brody'll
long duration terms it just doesn't make
a lot of difference if you do now if you
are a futurist you're not a prophet who
can raise a conquering army and change
the world by yourself if you conquer the
world everybody calls you that tyrant
they would never call you the futurist
so you know the benefit is not that you
transform history through some kind of a
cult understanding of the passage of
time or some you know amazing insight
into trends that nobody else knows about
the major benefit is that when seemingly
weird stuff happens you're rather less
weirded out than most people you you
kind of saw it coming you can even
console them so you know let me
summarize where I've gotten so far and
you know the the craft of how to be
futuristic okay first you got to find
some other futurists you need to learn
to think and talk like them kind of
adopt their jargon you know really
really kind of ingratiate yourself with
them they're your you're your colleagues
your allies then you need to find a
specialty audience in some pace layer
you know people who you can't predict
all the future to everybody on the world
at all times that's like pick a period
of future like short term middle term
long term and then a group of people
actually want to know and you have to
like understand what they want to hear
about their future if they're if they're
plumbers they want to hear about the
future of plumbing
right it's a very interesting topic wait
way down there in the infrastructure
level I can promise you a lot of
plumbing problems especially in like
cities going underwater
you would think yeah well plumbing is
like kind of a hoppin thing when like
the sea is coming up through the toilet
you'd be surprised really so you need a
specialty audience and you can't be a
snob about it and you need to try to
stay alive yourself for a while because
you need some hands-on experience with
the nature of time passing you know
otherwise you just you know you're kind
of sophomoric about it you're just not
very experienced and you don't really
know what it means to have leaves fall
off the calendar so you need a certain
amount of seasoning to be a successful
futurist you need you need to get a feel
of how the passage of time actually
affects people and you need to seek out
some long-dead allies in the classics so
that you can like get familiar with some
genuinely slow and long-term processes
and you're not merely some parochial
hick of your own decade so if you do all
of those things and you also do some
original creative work you know just
investigate some aspect of things that
are going on and you publish that and
you call it futuristic and the other
futurists agree and the public agrees
and they say yeah well that's some of
that futurist stuff then you are being
futuristic that's how it's done I mean
that's pretty much how it gets done
everybody does it that way there really
isn't any other way to do it so I do
that I don't do a ton of it because I
really don't like to work hard you know
but but I don't want to like stay in
here and boast about my alleged you know
futuristic accomplishments or appraise
my own prescient or any of that stuff
instead in the rest of this presentation
which is kind of cracking right along I
want to I want to acquaint you with some
problematic areas where I myself really
don't know
how to be futuristic this is like I kind
of like take you into the shop by just
kind of show you some of the ropes here
daily situations where I'm radically
uncomfortable and I feel like my
futuristic toolset is just not working
so you know sometimes I could see the
scope of this problem but I can't yet
grasp it
I don't have like a cultural sensibility
for it I kind of know what it looks like
but I don't know what it feels like I
don't have like an authentic you know
mode of emotional apprehension for it I
can't convince people with it because
like mostly because I can't convince
myself so let's consider the historic
city of Turin where I spend a lot of
time during our 21st century so I was
asked to go to Turin Torino to be the
curator of a high-tech electronic art
festival got tons of stuff like this
heaps of it and when I arrived there
everybody knew I was this foreign
science fiction writer and this futurist
so I was immediately treated as a
futurist by the public and that was not
not a problem I'm just in Turin I'm just
super futurist guy everybody knows that
so you know Turin is like the Detroit of
Italy it's a heavy industrial town where
the car industry Fiat collapsed suddenly
in the 1970s so it has a lot of
environmental legacy problems and it's
also quite high-tech I mean it's got a
lot of boutique manufacturing in Turin
and some brainy Polytechnic educators
but it's also a center of governance and
it's a town which is about the size of
Austin Texas or Belgrade in Serbia or
other towns where I spend a lot of my
time and I like these midsize talents I
mean I just find them literary and it's
kind of easy to like put your feet up
and think about novels and you know the
phone doesn't ring off the wall that's
the proper size of a city for me and I
consider Turin one of my home so I'm
just like I don't need a map I know
where all the streets are I know what
I'd like to eat you know I'm like I'm
not acculturated but I'm accustomed to
it so you know I find the tourney's
historical situation interesting on the
ground it's just like a ton of cool
weird stuff going on in which I can kind
of dabble or amuse myself and I'm an
intellectual butter
by my nature I just like to combine
far-fetched ideas and hang out with
innovators and you know that's that's
what gets me out of bed in the morning
so it followed that in Turin or to Reno
as they prefer to call it I do a lot of
stuff inside abandoned buildings because
that's what they have that's their
regional competitive advantage I mean
they they had an industrial collapse and
now they're they're a European city
which is growing after losing a lot of
its population but there's just like a
lot of space I mean just kind of like
cheap rent by European standards right
so if you're if you're participating in
the life of turin you're basically in a
life of urban renewal and that's what
they want to do on the ground that's
what the mayor talks about all the time
that's one that's within the newspapers
you know that's what they're up to
they're a group of people who are
repairing and upgrading an old city now
and they have various techniques for
doing it but everybody in turin wants
the sort of light bring the place back
to life and have it flourish and kind of
fill the empty buildings and find like
new ways to occupy the dead husk of the
20th century's industrial base and so
forth and so on and if you hang out with
them and you're like you're
participating well you know that's
that's what you do so I do and I do
projects such as Casa Yasmina which is a
house of the future project which is a
little residency in a formerly disused
Factory
it's a foundry a foundry uh you know
owned by Fiat but abandoned in the 1970s
so we moved into the place and we're
kind of lofting it out and we get like
tax breaks for it because the city
approves of activities of this kind so
we have like the Torino Fab Lab in there
and you know Neil Gershenfeld is doing
video through the wall all the time and
we have the Arduino allied electronics
thing where they're doing a lot of
electronic art like this except it's
more functional and
and we have opened a lot of open-source
hardware we have like robots routers 3d
printers but you know the Caza Yasmina
project is about all these things as
seen within a domestic context it's like
a house of the future project if you
built a torinese house using these
technologies like open-source
electronics open-source Hardware maker
gear routers like Dell digital
manufacturing if you made a house the
future that was produced by these maker
style methods or these MIT Fab Lab
methods what would that house look like
I mean what would it be like to occupy
it and what would you eat where we just
sleep what kind of decor would you have
why not try that experiment and why
don't just like build a house move in
and like you know will carry out the
performance of being a futurist and a
futurist house so the wife at AI which
is the Yasmine of kazuya's bina we
involved ourselves in this deliberately
futuristic effort not hiding that it was
futuristic on the contrary promoting it
cuz a Yasmina is very much a classic
house of the future showpiece within the
long tradition of houses of the future
like a traditional house of the future
it's about architecture and renovating
architecture and about interior design
and furniture and color schemes and home
automation and similar things that
Italians naturally find interesting just
when they're into design that's the kind
of thing Italians do and it was a really
fun scheme for an American futurist to
cook up and get away with it just like
it's not a novel or a short story but
it's a cultural intervention and it's
something we did very deliberately as
kind of a contribution to our community
there and cuz he has minas sitting there
in turin right now and probably there's
some like Politecnico graduate students
in there making some pasta for lunch and
like gossiping about Google because that
that's what they do and it's a house of
the future that is four years old
because you know we like came up with
the scheme some time ago and it's so
it's an established
residency I mean people show up they
stay there you can sleep in there you
can have a shower you have a pretty nice
party in Casa de Yasmina not as big as
this but you know half as big as this
it's doable it's got a bar a lot of
liquor and got a lot of Prosecco
everybody who enters cause Yasmina gets
to have a free Prosecco it's part of our
tradition there it has a technical
library a lot of weird technology art
there the Italian design press like this
project a lot got covered by Abbot re
Domus you know all the regulars
sometimes people from the City Council
drop by as yes Mina and I performing
futurism for people using a house to do
it and that's that's what we're doing
and they were appreciative I mean
they're a kindly audience and Torino
they think we're cute you know I think
they like having forward futurists
around doing weird futuristic things
like why not I mean they work cheap and
they're kind of up to all kinds of
mischief and you know why wouldn't you
want to cover that you know however our
futurist performance was not the truth
about turin mostly it's an assemblage of
the elements in contemporary turin that
a guy like me would find most
interesting it's really me like curating
parts of turin it's not really a house
that is a house of turin it is a sort of
a house of the future of turin and you
know quite fictional in a lot of ways so
i am a futurist but i'm also an art
critic and a design critic so i can go
downstairs to the Torino Fab Lab and I
can hang out with these people there and
I can like blow on the coals and I can I
can stoke a futuristic scene in a
foreign town and you know being a
futurist I actually have the ability to
do that and it's a cultural activist
scene in Turin which has a rather whole
earth style tools and ideas feeling of
deliberate accessibility I mean it's not
from San Francisco but there's there's a
definite open source flavour of like
okay let's just like spread these things
like have you tried this have you worked
on that pro-v amo you know it's an
experimental space which is you know not
the same as like a 1970s
counterculture drop cities scene but
it's in that cultural tradition I mean
you can see that it's like the same
thing happening just with like regional
flavor and like some upgrades of the
hardware however there are other aspects
of Turin which I noticed instantly as
soon as I arrived in the city and this
is the kind of culture layer the legacy
of the Turin which was a deliberately
planned futuristic city built about four
hundred years ago so there was also a
different Turin which was the Roman Al
gustatory nor Rome which was two
thousand years old but this room and
said he was just a small village
basically a roadside fort there scarcely
a trace left of that original Turin but
this baroque Turin of the 1600s which
was mostly constructed throughout the
17th century was very carefully mapped
out and planned by some very farsighted
forward-thinking people even the baroque
buildings of turin and there are many
that survived they have all kinds of
intense geometric stuff going on with
lots of parabolas and conic sections
very technocratic there it's it's the
handiwork of future minded technical
intellectuals who are creating a bravura
showplace for the most advanced concepts
in government and infrastructure of
their time so as soon as I was walking
around and these immense marbled arcades
of downtown Turin I immediately realized
well this is just not a normal European
city this is a planned Brasilia here
this is the capital city of an
autocratic utopia it looks kind of
French and somewhat Swiss but mostly it
looks like a military science project
it's built for artillery fire basically
that's why the streets are straight and
there's like these careful kind of
alignments it's built to resist cannon
fire but mostly it's built to deal out
cannon fire so it's a scientific for
to a city for an era of triumphant
artillery a kind of Mediterranean
Prussia
that's what Turin is and it's the
dynastic work of the savoy regime who a
very old european royal family who
eventually ended up as the Monarchs of
the Kingdom of Italy these were the
aristocrats who United Italy and the
Risorgimento and they became the royal
unifiers of Italy among many similar
aristocratic clans mostly because they
could really dig into their native
landscape and survived sieges with some
very clever architecture and they're not
dead yet this old Italian royal family
in fact thee they did get deposed after
World War two because they had favoured
Mussolini but the current royal
pretender that king of Italy is in fact
a rather good-looking young guy who owns
a food food truck in Los Angeles
very nice food truck I follow him on
Twitter he's a charming guy he's got
kids good-looking kids the royal family
is not gonna die with this guy I could
pretty well promise you so you know
these are city planners who built to
last I mean downtown Turin has about a
Megaton of these surviving four hundred
year old baroque buildings are very hard
to destroy they're mostly brick because
brick absorbs cannon fire but there's
some marble and even by military
standards these are some alarmingly
stout urban structures and some of them
get abandoned for a hundred years or
more they don't fall down they don't rot
they don't collapse
they just silently endure they're like
Egyptian pyramids and eventually people
show up again and they tend to just loft
them out so you know now they're all
over the place and they're not
aristocratic buildings of course they're
museums archives hospitals cultural
centers grocery stores tourist
attractions futuristic planned palaces
that just won't go away I mean they just
don't wear out that's why their future
estate it has been there all the time
and I have one of my own now
so you know in my bag here I've got some
postcards of my pet tourney's 375 your
old palace oh yeah Thank You Stuart
yes that's that that's our latest
tourney's renewal project the Phoenix
renewed so we're trying to find a new
tenant who will move into this palace
and renovate this palace and then this
tenant needs to stay there for about 60
years that's right they're trying to
find a guy with some staying power and
you know it'll take about a hundred and
fifty grand to maintain the palace and
it's Gardens which are very extensive is
like four stories high I mean it
basically has about the same square
cubic metre egde as your odd building
here I mean you're you're in a stuffed
animal building of some kind you know
and this is a similar thing I mean it's
a big it's got the volume of your thing
you're it's just that it's it's it's
baroque in its 17th century and it's got
like paintings and statuary and
chandeliers and carpets and that's our
writer office so you know we were done
with our house of the future project and
in our in our factory when we got this
call from the local Cultural Foundation
who were called the company of st. Paul
the Campania to San Paolo and they're a
non-governmental Enterprise in Turin an
NGO and they're 500 years old I really
they've been around half a millennium so
these guys are running this 500 year old
charity and they happen to be fans of
ours it turns out they really like to
read science fiction so they asked us
you know if we would leave our house the
future and we would do a video to
advertise one of their palaces to
attract possible new tenants because
they managed this brick palace which is
up in the hills and it's called the
delightful vineyard of the Royal madam
you know the vineyard madam oh really
and it's a place with a rather checkered
history so it turns out that this palace
of this villa our new office was built
by and for a guy who was one of my
favorite torinese historical characters
I didn't realize it was actually his
palace until we'd like moved into
place but I consider him a kind of
ultimate torinese historical character I
know a lot about him it's a super
interesting guy to me
and just never expected that he would
become my landlord so we know we went
into this baroque palace and they gave
us the formal tour of the entire thing
top to bottom so he went up the Attic
which is this amazing looking crooked
Garret we said wow what a fantastic
office for creative writers and actually
the entire building was a historical
archive that was its most recent use
mostly it was stuffed full of 500 years
of financial records centuries of them
just all over the place
financial banking records but it was
empty because the archivist had
digitized the records and they'd like
left the place so it was record free and
now and they are looking for a new
tenant so we volunteered and we moved in
and we don't reside in our palace and we
certainly can't afford it there are no
bedrooms in there but when we're in our
when we're in Turin we commute to our
Palace at 9 a.m. and we go up to the
attic we plug in the old computers and
we have at some creative writing and the
palace and then we leave promptly at
5:00 because they lock the whole place
up electronically and we go back to our
actual apartment which is a completely
different area of Turin we don't rent
the palace
we don't pay us to be there just kind of
a friendly understanding we're just
residents in the palace I'm the
visionary and residents at the villa are
big and you know we write novels about
turin and except for one security guard
board guy downstairs reading sci-fi
novels we are the only people and this
huge ancient building I mean we're just
like the modern ghosts and this 375 year
old structure it's just us and that
statuary and the priceless paintings and
the chandeliers and the giant carpets
and the many other relics and the huge
weedy garden and the secret tunnels and
the weird lake with the Opera set on a
little island and a greenhouse and big
urns that are like shrouded in ivy and
it's not a house of the future but it is
our Palace of the past and when we're
not around we really kind of miss it
it's surprising how quickly you can get
used to palatial Sir
Condon's so you know I know this sounds
rather comic and Isis the sci-fi writer
is marooned inside the ancient palace no
it's like an it Alok Alvino story right
it's just it's oxymoronic and it's got a
lot of like trick reversal kind of stuff
going on but it is certainly the
weirdest thing that ever happened to me
in Turin right and it has it has some
element of karmic retribution
right so it's like you're a guy you're a
futurist
and you claim to be outside of time I
mean you have some some higher
understanding of historic processes and
and you even have the power to do weird
things and empty factories because you
can like convince people to help you but
that car Factory is merely 100 years old
you should try some of your cheap
futurist magic tricks with this other
building from another pace layer
entirely 375 years old UNESCO World
Heritage Age building so despite this
huge gap in time I am alarmingly
intimate with the people who built this
palace
I mean I'm squatting their place now I
used to think of them as something like
spiritual ancestors are kind of like
remote weird wealthy aristocrats but now
I consider them more like my partners in
crime I really feel like a kind of
unusual involvement with them now you
see our Palace was never an official
building it was a secret building it's
actually a semi clandestine country
retreat it was built so that a duchess
and her henchmen could have a love
affair inside it actually a love nest a
huge love nest but you know a covert
love nest
so the Duchess of Savoy of that
particular period a French princess
named Christina was a widow and she was
a matriarch and the regent of the
country as her sons grew up and
naturally she had a prime minister
and he was this brilliant technocratic
manager named Philip st. Martin
so this widowed Duchess and her favorite
minister Philips st. Martin were a very
hot item it's just that nobody was ever
supposed to officially admit that and
you just couldn't say it everybody knew
it I mean everybody in the court into it
and and everybody's diplomatic corps do
it but it was common knowledge among the
cognoscenti even the people do it just
that nobody was supposed to speak about
it right a very French style louis xiii
situation right
mostly because Cristina was the sister
of louis xiii
right so you know they just had this
kind of you know your basic kind of
covert yet obvious romance and you kind
of like cloistered and closeted and yet
outed right so our palace is this covert
romantic getaway outside the capital
turin it's kind of torinese versailles
right where the court can retire from
the city kind of go behind walls and
their big walls their fortress walls and
let their powdered hair down and
everybody who visited our palace knew
that Cristina and Philip were having an
affair in there and of course they would
bring their own secret lovers to our
palace and nobody was judgmental because
the palace was a special zone of kind of
exclusion so then they're in there
playing charades and they sing and they
drink and they invent opera and ballet
and they dress up and they play the harp
and they pretend to be nymphs and
shepherds and everything is supposed to
be lovely except nothing is fine and
nothing is lovely on the contrary the 30
Years War is going on it's really a
severe sinister situation everything is
terrible
they're like military disasters at every
hand witch hunts literal wit shots like
mass burning and hanging which haunts
epidemics the Black Death assassins
scandals bankruptcies huge military
disasters the Inquisition is torturing
people not like
in tens of thousands Phillip st. Martin
gets kidnapped by Cardinal Richelieu is
literally abducted hidden in the
Bastille in a prison guarded by
Musketeers
so these buildings and these palaces
which seems so rational cold elegant a
bomb shelters really they're being built
in tragic tumult Turin is a planned
utopia which is very carefully thought
through on paper the same building
schemes are meticulously followed for
150 years by generation after generation
of autocrat but they're entirely rooted
in weird chaos just heresy madness
massive political and cultural breakdown
Germany is in total state failure
they're huge tides of homeless Marauders
who are burning and sacking everything
in sight 1/3 of the population of
Germany has been killed England has a
civil war the defeated queen is
Christina's sister so I don't want to
get into the tall historic weeds here no
there's no particular reason you should
suffer for my homework or what but what
but what really what really interests me
I mean like what baffles me about these
torinese baroque utopians is there a
fantasy world it's their fantasy world
how much they conceal how much they deny
how much they lie in every document now
we like to think that the judgment of
history is a court that brings justice
right that separates truth from falsity
I no longer believe that after these
researches these people are
Machiavellian court and treaters they
lie to everybody including one another
they don't tell people the truth because
they don't value truth it's just not in
their to-do list they value grandeur and
splendour and power and wealth and also
technical learning but their
pre-scientific they're not rational as
their geometric but they're not
scientific they do not verify reality
they do not test theories that hasn't
been
invented yet on the country their
fantasies like making this stuff up
Phillips st. Martin is the present Prime
Minister of the country because he is a
public relations expert who specializes
in glamourous spectacles he organizes
gorgeous public events that are the
ancestors of today's ballet and opera
just kind of tournaments in the streets
these are the great media events of his
day his firework shows the elaborate
baroque costumes the performances the
dances there likes television
spectaculars Philip st. Martin is a
courtier he's a power broker he's an
urban planner he's a massive builder but
it's spectacle through which he
justifies and legitimates his regime
he's in power because he makes stuff up
not because he really builds it he
justifies everything with fantasy he
takes the royal people of his court not
particularly attractive people to
standard European aristocrats he dresses
them up as mythological figures gods
goddesses demigods Shepherds nips
legendary creatures fairytale creatures
opera creatures creatures from ballet
and even though this guy is a technocrat
and a bureaucrat and a financier he
literally controls the entire budget for
state construction
he's the country's top real estate
contractor he never makes a factual
statement he never declares a manifesto
it's all done through showmanship it's
all spectacle pretense he creates the
urban fabric of turin by making stuff up
so i'm troubled by my relationship to
him I feel that in some way my bluff has
been called now when you're a Fanta cyst
you don't expect to look into the past
and be confronted by a better Fanta cyst
a guy who's like operating at a higher
level than you right and he is better or
at least he's certainly bigger and
better financed than me I mean after all
I'm staying in this guy's palace
he's not staying in my like little house
on the future over in the factory now
and even the palace itself is deceitful
by the way it was called the villa of
the Royal madam but I'm pretty sure it
was actually the villa of Philip st.
Martin I think he built it for his own
purposes the Duchess needed a place to
hide her lover so he built the palace
and said it was for her but he hid there
and she after she died he remained on
the grounds of that palace safely out of
the way of the next generation of
autocrats who naturally didn't much care
for him so I'm in the Attic of the guys
secret hideout basically that's our
relationship now even if I met him
personally somewhere if I could
interview face Philip st. Martin
face-to-face as a journalist maybe wired
but send me that would be nice and even
if he wanted to help me with my problems
I'm not sure that we could clear all the
fantasy out of the room and reach any
kind of historical truth I have the
feeling that between the two of us it's
pretty much fantasy all the way down I
don't understand how the truth could be
recuperated in this situation I was like
and actually the truth of what happened
historically like what happened when for
what reason who what when where hi why
how right we're simultaneously too close
and not close enough the passage of time
divides us but also unites us and I'm
not sure how to feel about that I find
it painful I'm tempted to simply laugh
it off you know make a joke of it just
declared to be surreal comically absurd
but you know I feel that's a cop-out and
I don't think Philips st. Martin would
agree with me doing that I think he
would say in his more melancholy and
baroque fashion that only God can be
all-knowing my difficulty is that I'm
demanding too much from the world he
would say that at the end for mortal men
like us all is vanity
because at the end of his own life
Philip st. Martin arranged to be buried
in a pauper's grave it literally had
himself disappeared you know he demanded
that no monuments be made of him he he
wanted to vanish so even though my
landlord Philip st. Martin is a rather
obscure regional figure
he's more futuristic than I am and an
alarming ways because he is classical
he's kind of like down in the culture
lair he was indeed one of the inventors
of classical opera and ballet so as long
as opera and ballet are understood as
art forms he'll be in the scholarly
footnotes there I mean you can't help
but stumble over him well science
fiction by contrast which is my art for
him is only ninety years old and there's
no guarantee it will last certainly not
as long as opera and ballet have lasted
it might well lose its cultural
relevance and just vanish into the
woodwork something like fantastic
debates about angels on the head of a
pin there used to be a lot of those and
people would read them and now we just
don't bother it just like there's no
there's no they're there for us so we
would not entirely surprised me of three
hundred and seventy five years from now
I am known to history as a very very
minor figure who once wrote something
about Philip st. Martin right posterity
does not reward us for thinking about
posterity posterity rewards us for being
a good posterity to those who came
before us so that's my problem
or at least it's part of my problem a
cultural problem and I haven't fully
described it yet to describe it I have
to put it into words I mean I actually
have to like come up with like that text
with like a beginning and a middle and
an end and some kind of like convincing
moral maybe but how would I conclude
that story I mean what is the moral of
that story I just don't know
or maybe I just don't know yet so I like
I do at the present historical moment is
conclude my speech so thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
please yeah no no that's that's that's
the long now gin right there one one
ovation is not enough can we get another
round of applause for our boys so so
that is the gin squeezed from
Bristlecone pine scream tune up yeah
yeah yeah a bit a bit I happen to be
violently allergic to the mountain
juniper but you know not not to its oil
it's only to the pollen EMTs raise your
hand
it's bianco okay I'm not a mountain
juniper from the American Southwest okay
that was pretty good thank you Bruce how
well come back more on the email if you
think you can help or if you want to
live in a palace or work in one there we
go
so first off a quick shout out to
borderlands books who are showing books
by mr. bruce sterling in the band I'm
not selling books I haven't written yet
I can promise you I'm gonna go back to
yesterday at the beginning of your talk
when you said
you said that one of the requirements is
that there are people that agree with
you well is it also yeah sorry that's a
validate is it is it also important
there are people that disagree with you
or at what point of those folks work
into the antibodies of that visionary
tendency get are needed and I don't
think agreement and validation of the
same things I mean you can be a very
very controversial futurist and do very
well and really if if you say something
that nobody objects you haven't really
said anything I mean there's got to be
some kind of kickback from some level of
a population I mean they're guys who
would like into their like the success
disk on doll or you know guys who are
really kind of futurist show people like
Norman Bel Geddes without you know does
sort of super blimps and giant kind of
attention catching things and you know
he got a lot of criticism from people at
the time like they're never gonna build
that Norman and I was like what are you
you trying to talk do over here but you
know he was a pretty successful guy and
you know he's a well-known industrial
designer but it was actually the profit
of the American interstate highway
system which is a super interesting
thing to me because you know he was very
interested in cars and roads and
infrastructure 'ti he wanted to work on
the infrastructure level and he
convinced people that the interstate
highway system we really like this
fantastic advance and it was but we
despise it and when you're on it you
don't think what a great thing I could
move across America there's hardly a
pothole
you know you think I'm stuck in a
traffic jam I could get killed here the
price of gas is like okay we've I
completely internalized it I kind of
like so he doesn't get he doesn't get
his credit as a profit for a great
technological advance we just see it as
background noise and annoyance you know
and that it's tough for us not too tough
for him I mean he died before that
happened but you know III look at him
and you know I look at Norman
you know people claim that Norman's
quite like a sci-fi writer because he's
doing all these sort of super giant
objects but they don't see that like is
great contribution as a thing that's
regarded as completely banal like one of
the most everyday aspects of American
life you know in it it affects everybody
who owns a car everybody who has to
commute they're all touched by Norman's
ideas and so you know his kind of
greatest success as a prophet as
something that we just stumble over and
dust ourselves off about we we don't
give him any credit all right I don't
know whether that's good or bad that's
how it is though so there's a time when
debates happen during debates when if
somebody says something about the other
candidate they give them the opportunity
to respond and I feel like Stuart I need
to give you the opportunity with the
pace layers analysis that was happening
if you if you're up for it or if you
want to think about it you certainly can
but there was an interesting explication
of the pace layers idea here and I
wonder if you've got anything not to put
you on the spot you want to say I think
you're doing a whole idea of use of pace
layers significantly and the idea that
various futurists camp out and the in
the layers and and that's where they can
make a living and be sort of self
consistent without having to fight
themselves which you do as soon as you
get in multiple layers because the
layers fight each other but I'm
interested in the way another thing
which is he raised the question of all
this dystopian science fiction going on
and the so-called Golden Age of science
fiction was very kind of upbeat utopian
and you know from Star Maker which is
about this utopian as it gets and he was
kind of you to have a socialist and
whatnot generational concerns seem to
have this kind of countervailing the
counter they're like I want to be the
mirror to the under
standings that I grew up with and so the
understandings that a lot of golden age
folks grew up with it was a [ __ ]
world war that was truly awful it was
really devastating talking about
dystopian she says burn a lot of the
major cities in the world right to the
ground they lived through that and but
the crunchiest opions didn't grow up or
anything like that they grew up with
technology getting better and better the
economics getting better better and all
that steven pinker world getting better
and better of childbirth is not killing
women the way it used to do all over the
world basically people getting out of
poverty is the main event the world
and these guys are doing worl just got
damn minute and then telling the counter
story is the counter story part of what
science fiction people do I actually
think we have kind of Soviet level of
dystopia is if you went you hung out in
the Soviet Union you can make the same
arguments it's like well you know
actually there's there's more roads and
like there's better buildings and like
the food is improved a lot since World
War two so you know why are you actually
like happy and upbeat about being a
Soviet right I'm like and the writers
Union they're like rewarded for that as
I only wrote a great novel about a
tractor and honestly they really brought
in the crops you know this is it's super
you know but um it was the lies that
corroded people's morale and I think
that's our actual problem now people are
dystopian because they know that the
major problems we face are being paid
for it over right that they're just not
and we're not dealing with the problems
that we have so there's like a loss of
legitimacy among institutions and you've
got people who basically are dystopian
but they're dystopian in the level of
like Soviet guys mumbling black humor
jokes to one another you know while
while avoiding the situation right and
you know I like to make historical
analogies but they don't they don't
always work perfectly or well and you
know there there are a lot of people in
Russia right now who are actually pretty
upbeat about the situation even though I
mean they're proud right they really
feel like they're off their deathbed and
kind of you know laying out with two
fists I mean they're there
f no nationalists Russian enthusiasts
and a lot of them are Christian
fundamentalist Orthodox Christian
fundamentalism and they do this even
though there's like a snowstorm of
official lies from the regime maybe they
just lie about everything routinely
sitting like guys with nerve gas at
London I mean they're lying so openly
and with such brazen lack of good faith
that it's almost like gloating and
they're actually clothing with the lies
at this point right so you know Russians
used to be the most dystopian sci-fi
writers especially if they escaped
Russia
whereas now the most optimistic winds
are probably Chinese you know you know
and you would not want to go to China
and so they'd say oh what a great place
I mean you know I have well you know
normally you would not say I'm going to
China for like the better way of life
that they have you know the Chinese
sci-fi writers are just like punching
way above their weight right now and
that this really is their Golden Age of
you know science fiction and they're not
writing dystopian stuff in fact they're
writing just really pretty good novels I
mean things that are kind of have
emotional depth and they've got vision
and they're not comic book II or stupid
they're not serving the regime they're
not they're really literate tours and I
was like they can really do it you know
they're like they're in they're in
they're in pretty good shape right so
you know how are you gonna explain that
okay I don't know I don't have like a
grand theory but it interests me a lot
that they're around and they're not
they're not utopia
I mean utopia thing is overblown I mean
people who wrote commercial science
fiction intended to write stuff with
upbeat endings especially in the US but
the best-known works of imagine if
fantasy are 1984 and brave new world and
you know other very serious somber kind
of geopolitical novels are all about
oppression and torture and official lies
and you know and deceit and hate and
murderer and you know phony nests and so
forth and days other things it really
mean these are the ones that are kind of
sunk down on the cultural level you see
Orwellian around you would see Palardy
and around you don't really seem Buck
Rogers and
it just seems childish so I don't know I
mean it's a matter of temperament
you know guys of my era I mean cyber
points were into dark euphoria and kind
of we're not into a sense of wonder
we're into light ecstasy and Dre okay I
mean ecstasy and read a stuff that you
see a lot
cyberpunk X it's like it's really
horrible and like oh but really really
amazing like I'm also really horrible
but like just fantastic I can't get up
my head around it it's like except this
legs been slowing off you know and it's
like and this is kind of a very
deliberate period sensibility that you
know sort of emerged from the 1980s and
you know you could see you didn't film
and the way people dressed and you know
that kind of thing and you know it was
fun to do that's kind of hadn't didn't
try it out but I don't have I don't have
a magic solution for it and I also don't
think that optimistic science fiction
actually makes anybody optimistic I
don't think that helps I don't think
that helps with the problem at all I
mean what makes people optimistic as
something to be enthusiastic about
that's why that's when people are really
optimistic they don't even ask if
they're in a good mood they just hop out
of bed because they like want to go do
it and we don't have a lot of things to
be optimistic to be enthusiastic about
like Moore's Law was something or the
internet was something but this is like
your uncle's job now we don't have like
something that like really makes people
like hop out and make it happen and if
we did the oligarchs you know would hit
it on the head or buy it or our or
suppress it in some way and I think
people know that so that's the actual
mm-hmm that's the actual what's the
right word for it malaise that's the
that's the Carter Eska malaise of our
era
we're not authentic
so and Joe Joe's got the the mic so get
his attention he will get it to you I
want to ask you it's really good gin by
the way yeah man is this is this really
gin it's really gin I'll tell you the
story afterwards but but let's make the
most of your time so so I want to ask
you something that's a little bit inside
baseball for science fiction writers but
it's actually something that is recently
I feel like being externalized and
talked about a bit and I'm curious
world-building
is a tool of science fiction writers and
it and again it's a tool that's being I
think talked about in a way that the
mechanics of writing aren't talked about
a whole lot usually four things is is it
a new phenomena or a more developed
phenomena in this era is is what are you
what are your thoughts or takes on it
and and towards the subject of your talk
here it seems like world building by
looking for an internal consistency to
this larger sort of system as opposed to
a more golden age sci fi or earlier
thing where there it may be a singular
aspect that makes everything ok and you
don't think about all the repercussions
is that what does that mean in terms of
this futuristic striving analysis that
you're you're you're you're thinking
about here well I used to do a lot of
that and I used to really like kinds of
fiction that had like you know building
stuff I mean it's just kind of the Pope
the elves thing going on where this like
you've got the made-up alphabet and the
kind of fake country you know and the
whole thing is worked out and kind of
exquisite george RR martin detail right
or polka so it does go back to talking
you know and I kind of you know we used
to praise that we call it imaginative
concentration it's like maybe the guys
really got really deep into this thing
and he's like invented the sink and the
dish and the sink and the leftovers and
addition to see that must be really good
acid it's going for a long time well you
know I think there's a there's an
aesthetic to that kind of built world
that people appreciate and they they
like it because you don't reveal all of
it to people I mean there's like more
going on than appears in the text and
that's when it feels like a built world
and and and and it's also interesting
too because are things like thieves
world or just separate there there if
there are few things where like multiple
writers can then engage with that
University I wrote some books like that
like schism attrex is a book of that
kind that's got just like tons of index
cards somewhere else you know like
elaborate relationships between
characters that are just not revealed to
the reader yeah there's this like gee
whiz this guy is like some kind of
anonymous fantastic historian you know
the things like really deep its it's
mostly about not showing people all of a
moving parts but in the meantime you
know and especially in the 21st century
there's been like severe like really
important kind of technical advances in
making prototype objects or just fake
things are like actually building a fake
world like kazuya's mina is a world
building exercise that turin would look
like if turin was built with open-source
methods right so it's like a house that
implies a city that doesn't exist right
and and it has fictional elements in it
like it has a kid's room which is full
of kid toys in a kid bed but there are
no children in that space there are
imaginary children but a house in the
future has to have children because the
without children there are no future
right well you know yeah I thought we
have these fake kids we didn't name them
but you know everything in the space is
like designed from their point of view
and like as a curator of Kazi as Mina if
a guy brings in a drill press from
downstairs I say you have to take that
out if it hurt the kids you know and
they agree oh well I didn't think of
that sorry mr. sterling but that's what
makes it look like a house right I mean
it actually looks like a residence even
though it has fictional residences in it
uh-huh
yes well home is not an Italian word
it's a casa but yeah I mean it has a
domestic flavor which is deliberately
put there as a world building element
and you can get away with that more
easily than you used to but but it's not
worked out actually ahead of time so
much as there's a sense of the mission
of
the homeless the COS honest of it I was
actually worked out as soon as we saw
the blueprints I mean when we studied
loft and out the thing it's like where's
the children's room hmm you know where's
the master bedroom and like it was built
for an imaginary family we never named
them but we knew they were torinese you
didn't go full persona but no but but we
could have and it wouldn't have taken
much and I don't think of it even of
slow people down like they could write a
novel set in kasi as Amina that has a
fictional family in it and you know it
probably do okay I mean and and in the
meantime there's just like guys in the
design world who can make prototype
objects or fictional objects or objects
that don't work and kind of promote them
through acts of design fiction or
architecture fiction and you know really
get a pretty good audience and even make
money like I was at CyArk a couple of
weeks ago teaching in the design school
in LA and you know talking to one of my
fellow instructors there I mean I'm not
an instructor I'm merely a passing guest
but he's like making up imaginary
buildings for cyber coin companies and
making a lot of money for it even though
they have absolutely no intention of
actually building these structures they
just want to show them to investors and
so to say after we've got 200 million
we're gonna like buy a big chunk of
downtown and we're gonna like put all
these cool Frank Gehry style imaginary
buildings in them and we have like a guy
on retainer who's like willing to come
in here and like help us with our Apple
style corporate headquarters you know
even though the entire thing is
basically a crypto coin put up job I
don't think they're ever gonna build
this thing there nevertheless rewarding
em for it and they're even having like
very elaborate arguments about what the
nature the buildings are do they have
ATMs for instance or should they look
like banks you know because crypto coin
people hate bankers they consider them
the class enemy so you know what is a
crypto called look like I mean you got
to hire somebody
we can't just draw it on a napkin so you
know I was I was boasting to this guy
about my fondness for paper architecture
and imaginary architecture things and
you know I get along at CyArk very well
not because I know much about
architecture but because I know a lot
about weird architecture I know really a
lot about weird architecture I know more
about weird architecture that most
professional architects would ever know
because they they don't pay any
attention to like the crazy stuff that
night didn't work and it's never gonna
work so you know we may be working on
some projects with these guys no I mean
for the kid no no I don't think they're
gonna be home Kasai our guys are like
big I mean they want to do like Frank
Gehry style stuff they want to do like
the Lord Norman Foster style artificial
architecture things they want to do
things like floating Zeppelin's in the
atmosphere of Venus kind of imaginary
architecture and you know their size by
writers could really help out a lot I
mean I promise you that if you want to
invent a floating Zeppelin and the
atmosphere of Venus and Neil Stevenson
drops by we're gonna have one [ __ ] of a
floating set that's really gonna scare
people
they might even faint you know people
will write doctoral dissertations about
it so the quicker side then we get to
this question you just gave a talk about
architecture that was great as far as I
got through it I was literally listening
to it in the office while doing it and
you had a line about blimps during that
talk which I laughed out loud and
embarrass myself a little bit at the
bank dude I don't know if you well you
know these things date back to laputa
which is sort of the first sci-fi blimp
like the city and the sky kind of thing
you know it's kind of standard and you
know and they never work I mean
Zeppelin's didn't really work out
cargo blimps they're basically toys
4-bit shows I mean they have beyond on
the side or whatever but now we've got
things like drones and these other kind
eriell structures and even like Google
loon which is sort of kind of a
commercial success I mean at least it's
like a lunatic kind of 100-day blimp
300-day I think so you know people
always yearn toward these things like
the flying car or no [ __ ]
and they are [ __ ] oh it's especially
I mean especially if they're that they
just sort of appear as a toy signifier
for some flat-packed future is like this
is futuristic because it's got a blimp
it's not gonna be futuristic because
it's got a blimp however you know it's
not it's not beyond the laws of physics
to actually build a floating city in the
atmosphere of Venus I mean that sounds a
lot weirder than a blimp but the people
are never going to live on the surface
of Venus but the atmosphere of Venus is
so thick that you can actually build
like a basically a Geodome I mean a
round thing and just kind of have a bob
around you know on the top of this
sulfuric murk and you know technically
speaking it makes more sense than like
an International Space Station because
those are very bad for your health
if you're on Venus you'd have normal
earth style gravity and you'd just be in
a big balloon right so I know I don't I
don't dismiss the idea of large floating
objects in the sky I don't think they're
not going to be built for the reasons
that guys who'd like to put blimps in
fake cities want to put blimps in fake
cities they would be built for reasons
of power governments Commerce fashion
whatever and it's really more of a
matter of the price point coming down
and somebody finding a killer
application for living and one of these
aerial structures and even an aerial
structure in the atmosphere of the earth
I think makes more sense than like a
moon colony you could build one really
and float up there indefinitely for
maybe a tenth of the price of a moon
colony maybe a twentieth of the price
just like when would you come down I
mean why why are you up there
just been do you really want to live in
a blimp good honestly
have you ever lived in an airport you
know you spent a lot of time have you
logged a lot of flying hours right so I
don't know I mean it's really an
interesting and interesting
architectural problem you know an
architects like megastructures they like
they like to think big right and I don't
have a problem with that I mean
architects are into space but they're
there in this sort of spatial management
every that's what they're kind of things
connect to things you know it's like
that's what they do is like this part
goes here and there's like this other
part and then like this part here and
like okay I mean maybe one of the
biggest problems with an aerial city is
it's hard hard to make that building
learn like honey how do you repair an
aerial structure on the fly if you
decide you need like a veranda you know
maybe you park it you deflate it what
what would you do with it I don't know I
could easily teach a course about that
at sci-arc if somebody wanted to hire me
to do it you know and we could do it we
could do furniture we could do you know
social media we could do we could do the
politics of that structure right we
could world build you know we could hire
you know X gbn guys if we had a Google
budget you know or a Marvel Comics
universe movie budget yeah you could
dress it up to the extent you want right
I mean just like invent the whole thing
shebang right which is not something you
could do you know 40 years ago in sci-fi
right I mean really you know if somebody
you know the Sheikh of Dubai wanted to
drop 15 million on an imaginary flying
city you can you couldn't build one but
you could build kind of every
appurtenance for one right and you could
just you could just hire experts and
have them work the whole thing out you
know there's there's nothing stopping us
you know except making it pay and that's
kind of probably easier than I thought
in a world that believes and stuff like
bitcoins
and in a way it's a secret of these
baroque palaces you know they're really
kind of not on the budget at all you
know they're just kind of thereby
autocratic decree yeah and they exist
pretty much out of sheer grandeur and
glamour people are kind of happy to
build them now as a town is so great and
our Duke is so wise it's like why have
you ever seen like this other town
like dirty and full of rat listen I
found this grand and full of marble and
you know and they're like the
populations will let it go with them so
just to review blimps [ __ ]
floating cities practical we have a
question there we go yeah Bruce Sterling
Ross Anderson longtime fan first-time
caller
how are you man it's good to see you
first of all I've seen a few talks in
this building this is the best one so
congratulations second all right that's
fair secondly at the beginning of your
talk you you laid out two versions of
the now one that's like at the immediate
quantum you know the speed of light by
an electron and the one that's a black
monolith you know God's standing out of
time and I want to know most days when
you're at the palace and you're thinking
where are you at and that continuum
between those two I'm actually kind of
the super-thin now version if I have to
pick between the two because you know I
I don't believe in predestination you
know I believe in like deterministic
chaos and a lot of these other kinds of
you know Ilya Prigogine style second law
of thermodynamics tough you know and I
think that the universe makes itself up
as it goes along out of thickets a
solemn thing but you know I I don't I'm
not convinced that we know what time is
and I'm kind of thinking we should be
ready for some kind of Copernican
revolution or it's like okay the
universe is 94% dark and
in dark matter and it's like 4% stuff we
can sense okay what the heck gives with
that I mean you know we're like some
kind of spews kind of situation so you
know I don't think expect this to happen
in my lifetime but you know there have
been I many many different meta
histories about what time is the kind of
theories of what time is and I don't
think we've reached the final one and I
just I don't think you know I would
suspend judgment on what time is I did
not mention like some of my personal
favorite wacky notions of time like
what's outside outside the light cone
right if you're into relativistic
physics as this thing of the light cone
right where the light cone is like
information can reach you because you
know that it can travel at the speed of
light maybe you can send something back
but then there's other things as the
universe continues to expand the light
cone can it gets narrower and there's
like larger and larger areas of time and
space that you can never ever learn
anything about listen it's not like an
event horizon it's just like literally a
distance right I mean they're just like
they're just like too far so you know as
a futurist I often wonder about what's
our more rural relationship to people
outside the time Colin I mean I mean we
could never do anything to them right I
mean they're just there's nothing we can
do good or bad we will never know
anything about them I mean they're just
permanently like monsters on the unknown
edge of the map and like should we worry
about them but should we think of I mean
we are outside their time cone by the
way I mean we're they're unknowable
monsters so late but they're like more
alien than aliens are in theory you
could like contact an alien these guys
are just like gone right but we're gone
from them so we're as real as they are
they're as real as we are they're just
like untouchable through any kind of
imaginary okay I say all right you can
think about the past and I have like
these problems where Phillips st. Martin
and our other kind of historical figures
are just problems with the idea of your
relationship to historical figures like
should you sympathize with should you
judge them rigorously is he a bad guy is
he a good guy but for somebody who's
outside the light cone
but I mean theological relationship to
somebody you know it's like are they the
accursed
right like I think do we even have words
for them and I'm it's just like it's
kind of interesting yes just like this
is right and then I even like angels or
you know mythological pigs are fantastic
big they're they're probably as real as
us they're just not reachable through
reality there's no there's no statement
you can make about them mmm okay I mean
maybe there should be no that bumper
sticker outside the light color I love
you coexist in the light outside the
light you know you there in the darkness
hi are you gaze into the abyss and the
abyss gazes back to you and it says
how's it going but but you're like
you're like waiting for a headlight to
reflect off the cave wall so you can get
an angle on them and make more of the
[Laughter]
light Khan is like different they're
like you know I read an article recently
by a guy who's like some kind of
homemade physicist and he's in a moral
panic that the idea that our life our
life cone is getting narrower like time
is passing is like we're running out of
opportunities to like go outside the
light gun and the longer we wait you
know it's like it's like a Verdun global
warming unless we like a tack bag of Dom
in a galaxy right now we're gonna end up
in a very narrow area of the future leg
come what we just can't can't reach the
things at all like we got a whip it and
nobody gotta really push that right
light speed drive get it right now it's
like things are twinkling we're being
crushed down into a needle like sheep
that's a very strange since
but you know I can imagine it becoming a
mass sensibilities hey like you know
it's like the future is being delimited
it's big you know whittled away whittled
away and I think what the guy is doing
is actually he's having a moral panic
about global warming which is merely
transforming into his apparent panic
over the light-cone but in a future
society where people do feel like their
lives are more and more delimited I can
see them like worrying about this on
some kind of cult level right like the
Church of the light-cone just like
smaller smaller we must fight our
imagination is being squished our tight
rope future the the alright we have give
the mic in someone else's hand there
okay it came to me
Alexis Madrigal hey Joan booth I you
know in some of your previous writing
you've referred to the dark euphoria
particularly after the financial crisis
in in the US today you talked about how
the dominant mode of society is dread
and I was thinking about the different
layers different pace layers and
wondering if dread and dark euphoria are
inhabiting different layers or whether
dread has has infected all of them
through time oh well you know if nature
goes the rest goes so if nature is
dreadful all other pace layers kind of
have to be dreadful in my opinion you
know in dark euphoria is like okay
things are dark but there's also just
like amazing potential lose it's like
ecstasy and dread but you know if
there's no particular signs of ecstasy
then the darkness is gonna dominate and
you know the euphoria could have
dominated and thinks it's kinda like
strange splendid things happen you know
like the events of 1989 they were very
euphoric and those can show up at any
time I mean you know Vaslav Havel set a
lot of wise things about that
and you know and kind of about the the
the innate instability of the passage of
time and how light you can do you can do
small gestures that suddenly radiates
throughout the body of society so you
know people can be very happy very
quickly and I was very interested in
those times in advance I mean it's a
it's a strange area you know the Czech
Republic it's a very nice biography
written by one of hovels followers which
I read where she's hanging out with some
of her activist friends in the street
and the regime has fallen and Havel has
been sworn in as president and she tells
her girlfriend this is the happiest day
of our life and that's a very euphoric
moment but it's also very dark and that
she's aware that no other day of her
life is gonna be this happy but this is
not the beginning of something good as
good as it could possibly yeah and this
is sort of as historically good as it
can possibly get you know and it's not
even that it goes downhill after this it
just becomes normal after this right and
you know that's kind of a dark euphoric
situation it's like okay I'm like
euphoric and then there's like this
clicking moment where I relocated world
hasn't actually changed I've just woken
up in bed with a different boyfriend you
know or whatever it was that kind of
good now he's like gonna be the husband
and you know I sank into his arms and
now my arms are in his sink you know and
I'm like carrying out a kind of normal
human human life right so you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of
dystopian American science fiction
mostly because they don't want to lie
right it's actually no it's actually
it's actually very hard and there are
people in this in science fiction who
are of the right but there are very few
people in science fiction who are
actually like lickspittles of the
establishment I mean they just don't go
along with it ever you know I'm they
have different areas of opposition or
visionary breakthrough areas where
they're trying to operate but it
surprises me how much integrity they
have actually
and I know they don't want to be this
dystopian they're just actually reacting
authentically you know to it to a
situation where you know a lot of people
who ought to be declaring it dystopian
are basically bullshitting the people
right we're just making up rubbish so
that's I don't know it's a sign of hope
in some ways right I mean if all the
science fiction writers were
collaborating to say oh of global
warming is not a problem and you know
our overlords in the banking system are
actually they really love us and there's
no problem with the NSA wiretapping
everything we do and we don't have to
worry about guys being nerve gas per cut
up with bone saws and Saudi embassies or
what whatever the whatever the atrocity
of the day was right I mean if science
fiction writers at all decided to be
upbeat yeh sayers this would be a sign
of worse crisis than them actually
responding to a dark situation in an
authentically dark way so so we are
gonna have to to bring this to an end
I'm afraid clock will continue to take
[Applause]
9000 settles nine hundred years ago yeah
so as a last question I mentioned at the
top of the show the whole earth 50th
anniversary just happened I'm curious
your professional futurist futurism
futuring continues a verb that it is you
and and and and I'm gonna call you out
as the the terminal editor of the Whole
Earth Catalog and you can explore three
other issues okay okay I didn't actually
bury the thing you
but you you you had you had the
potential the issue that never actually
saw the light of day
yeah it was like close to an admitted
yeah we can talk more about that Bruce
is gonna stick around his books are
gonna be on sale please all stick around
and keep this conversation going he'll
be signing books afterwards as well so
you've read more Whole Earth Catalog
than I have as a certain folks in the
first couple rows here but as I've
looked it at more one of the things I've
thought about is that almost every
article in Whole Earth Catalog
or the and I should say the the family
of publications coevolution quarterly
and the whole review there's a lot of
thinking about the future going on in
those stories it's not a world building
world it's a lot of time something like
mushrooms will change everything
solar panels are going to make
everything different in the process of
maybe not writing those articles but
certainly of editing those of seeing
them all coming reading through them
it's clear that these can't all possibly
be true because in part they don't even
know about their neighbors in the same
issue let alone the guy who may have two
years ago given a different mushroom
vision of the world so to speak so
inherently there's a knowledge that
talking about the future and projecting
the future is flawed that it's wrong
that it can't be completely right or
that not all of them can be completely
right so is it still a good exercise to
do not as a professional knitted
together taking the holistic kind of cut
of everything going on sort of approach
but as individuals as writers or is just
people in this room on Twitter or
whatever
what is the rather than the the trying
to be right kind of future the failed
flawed maybe kind of futuristic endeavor
what are your thoughts about that on as
an individual and a group or community
kind of exercise uh well you know I
don't think there's like the one future
so I think that's
of ideas go on I mean if you do like
quadrant forecasting which is like
something I really like to do you're
kind of dividing up ideas of the future
and delight different kinds of arm camps
and it always says why this is the slow
win and this is the fast one and like
this is the weird one and this is like
the poor women this is the rich one and
you always think ok well only one of
these is going to work but that's not
actually the case they all come true at
the same time it's just that one of them
dominates and the other one is some kind
of like weird minority notion so you
know the thing about whole earth I mean
looked at historically like people like
a hundred years from now or 150 years
from now who are like looking through
old microfiche --is because probably all
that digital stuff will be gone but you
know there will be things around and
when they're looking at it I think what
they're going to look at it and sort of
judge it is like that it's very
Emersonian that it's actually all about
American individual action right it's
like the personal this and the personal
that so if you're like going through the
whole or a thing it really makes kind of
grandiose wills and claims that sort of
say socialism will triumph and
everything's going to be it's more like
this might make you enthusiastic or you
know try it out you can get it in the
mail as I gets cheap and you could like
have five right you know and light and
you could do it and I what do you need
the state why do you need the government
you know nobody knows what's really real
let's just explore every possibility
and we're like leave you here if you
don't like it you just flip the page and
you like to have the other thing right
cool and the apotheosis of that attitude
is the personal computer where you've
got like one sort of gadget but you can
afford which is on the desk and it's
just for you and this is for you and
it's not like for the government or you
know the corporation or whatever and you
can set it up the way you want and you
can like pick your own font so your and
you know and there's like and it
empowers you to do all kinds of stuff
you could do math you can like
communicate with people and so forth and
so on
so you have a kind of super power to
Emersonian individual who's like Thoreau
really I mean you can go into the bean
Shack except now he's got like this
super device we can kind of connect him
all over the world and he can like find
out all this kind of stuff and like
rampe himself up to the I'm being pretty
good at being god-like situation right
and no and that actually worked but only
for our historical period because the
personal computer is dead I mean nobody
has a personal computer
everybody's computers are social and
mostly their element they're they're
mostly for commerce and for surveillance
that's their actual purpose now and when
it doesn't mean that like this was a
wrong attitude this is a historical
development it's like being amazed at
like that Ford Model T is turned into a
traffic jam
that there's some electronic ones now or
that or that there's self-driving ones
like the Google X car I was in today
right which like moves you silently
around the landscape of Mountain View
while also spying on you just all the
time personal car right it's like I got
into the car and it threw me out I say
okay I have delivered you to point a
well can I go back to the Google
headquarters no you have to call another
car because it's like program to move me
across the Google map it's not actually
a car at my command yeah I mean it's a
web-based transforming transportation
service and I don't get to take the car
back to where it came from I have to
download another car app service and
then get back into this vehicle which
turns out to be the same vehicle I just
I just went around the block and like
pick me up and move me and the other
direction okay you know blaming Henry
Ford for that as like a category I'm
like blaming whole earth for its it's a
championship of the individual and then
realizing that that actually leads to a
kind of oxymoronic situation of unsought
communication to you know very large
forces okay that happens in historically
all the time right you're not even wrong
and doing it it's just what happens it's
like the consequences are built on top
of the other consequences so you know I
think we're in a an era of political
strife and when possibly Bonaparte ISM
right because you know there seem to be
a lot of tyrants and Ollie
ARC's around yeah who actually want they
don't want to seek out elections and
they don't they don't really have a
program they just want to use social
media to kind of turn themselves into
you know gigantic kind of outsized
figures and you know I think that's this
air is gonna pass too but it's not a
very obvious right I mean this is kind
of what the next decades are holding for
us and in a lot of ways it's a return to
the historical elements that were very
common in the 1600s the 1700s of the
eighteen hundreds it's not a singularity
you know it's much more like the
troubled world of the 30 Years War or a
kind of long emergency situation or even
like periods in which China was a very
optimistic and outwardly focused major
superpower you know which China has not
been for a hundred and fifty years but
historically there's been many periods
where they were just like taking no
prisoners and it's like really on top of
their game okay
they're you know if you study eras of
history in which that occurred you're
actually looking at predictions of our
future which are probably more accurate
right and that's for you know
establishing catalogues and like
throwing a lot of lit matches in a lot
of different directions you know I have
to say I'm very fond of that I mean you
know personally I do that all the time
and I give people like really weird
ideas like much weirder ideas that most
you would see in whole world and really
just kind of throw them around you know
from a kind of court jester you know
kind of situation and I don't seek
political power and I don't really want
to be rich I don't even want to run a
magazine it's like too much work I'm a
person who like kind of pollinates in
that wonder or you know maybe not Paul
about pollinates maybe to kind a word
maybe I might go setting fire to things
unfortunate ways or sprinting subversive
activities or fertilizer yeah you know
just [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well you know this is a temperament
which is very whole or at the end and
you know it's not it's not something I'm
willing to sacrifice and I recognize
that it's gonna be an old-fashioned
attitude in some ways like open source
is not going to conquer the world it's
gonna have a niche right and they're
gonna be people using it who you don't
expect and I was very interested in that
and I liked it because of its
information wants to be free aspects but
you know there there are consequences to
information being free that are severe
and long-lasting if the information
wants to be free doesn't mean
information wants to be good and it
doesn't mean the good information wants
to be free like fake information wants
to be free
evil information wants to be free or
fraudulent kolp information right and so
forth and so on
and you know I'm kind of willing to take
the historical consequences you know I'm
not gonna be like morally judgemental
about myself and you know I think I
think in terms of like most magazines
that were established in the 1960s for
like 68 or reasons you know a whole
earth holds up pretty well I mean if you
read whole earth and you read like
situationist tracks whole earth is
actually a lot more interesting then
stuff that the since were up to you know
they just had a different approach to
stuff it did have the problem of evading
you know of concentrating on the
individual and hiding the larger flaws
in the system because the world is not
the fault of the individual individuals
are very temporary and you know we can't
save the world alone and we don't
condemn the world alone and there is
something very American about whole
earth and the way that British would say
they're hard isolated stoical and
killers you know that that's the
American temperament the frontier
temperament in particular like I'm on
the end and endless frontier can
ceaselessly developing myself I'm hard
I'm isolated I'm stoical and I'll kill
right it's like yeah I don't know
because I'm American and I've got
handguns no and that's what we really
like and we really really really like
them and they're very holworth in a lot
of ways because they're always
pretending that it's like me and my a
kay we're subtly gonna bring justice
everybody down at the elementary school
right or are they drugged you know the
opiate thing that we have now just like
okay it's me and this needle and like
I'm gonna solve all my problems by like
injecting this thing into myself well
that's not where your problems came from
right but from an American and you know
an American individualistic society
these are the kinds of neuroses that
arise from putting too much weight on
the sovereign individual he just can't
do it all right any more than you can be
a futurist alone on the beach with a
stick it just can't be done well yeah
you know but holer tended to pretend
that that could be done it's like I'll
just take this hit of acid and I'll
become like Kali like no I mean you
could take the hit of acid but it
doesn't really loft you to a higher
space where you stay there you're just
eating an intoxicant and in eight hours
you're gonna be pretty much what you
were before I that's a fun experiment
shame it didn't work now maybe someday
it will but every one because because
one guy did acid it'll be because
several million people are doing
whatever it is that actually puts people
into some other kind of neurological
thing so you know I don't think history
will deal kindly with it but I think
probably it'll have a bigger of
reputation as time passes that people
would think there's just so many echoes
of things in there that people the
future people will be able to identify
well I mean it's just there's so much
barrier where you're stopped in there
you know some of its gonna grow and then
they'll say oh yeah this isn't like page
38 of
sheer number 75 I mean there's a lot of
stuff whole earth was noticing that most
people and trying to summarize it which
was good and I used to read you know I
heard like some vague rumors of this you
know what is it
oh well that's useless you know it's
like it allows me to like focus my
attention on stuff that I actually I
said that I quoted that in a tweet today
right which is kind of negative
intellectual generosity yeah it's like
let me let me try to persuade you to be
interested in this it's like no so it's
the pages you skip are more valuable
than the ones you actually read figure
out what that scene is like and just go
somewhere else with a scene yes that's
more attractive to me you know I don't
even have to condemn them I'm just like
got no time for that one yeah you know
that's like too many other good stuff
good things going on yeah so it was kind
of a curatorial effort in that way and
it didn't tell you not to do it it's
like this is the bad thing just kind of
like these guys think it's great then
you look at it like these guys are no
wait I just know not them anybody but
yeah I really it really helped a lot
it can't be an expert on well Bruce
thank you so much for this I
let's give Bruce round of applause
is the along now challenge coin
carpe millennium and just a reminder to
all of you this is as good as it gets
[Applause]
[Music]